hello everyone welcome to a brand new
episode of the witching hour yet another
special one because we seem to have
really great luck with guests we have
one great guest after the next of course
it is it chapter 2 time I'm sitting here
on Perry
that's Hayley but the person you need to
know right now is James Ransone PJ
actually right well you know I mean we
can call me PJ when the cameras are all
okay okay just curious where did the
name come from i I'm not gonna I can't
I'll just tell you that this the Jay in
the name is short for Jimmy but I will
not tell you what the P stands okay my
real name is James no it's not that it
was think it actually helped to be like
if someone calls the house and were like
who's James that it's a police officer
I'm like oh this person knows my formal
name but they don't know me personally
okay I did I wasn't calculated
I was very thrown off at the junket the
other day with oh they were like DJ that
was also kind of like some of that was
just now it's just gonna stick but it
was uh it was too hard because of McAvoy
- James I'd be like which why well I
keep effing up bill bill hater
yeah but then there was Andy machete and
Andy bean oh boy wow I would have seen
ya so you have quite a few horror
credits to your name yeah oh yeah yeah I
still have my sinister poster yeah yeah
- Sinister's you worked with ty west
before it's a oh I guess I always
figured that ty gets paid is like a hard
or like a Western anyway
no no I'm just met Morris that we were
we're such close friends for so long
that I just the conversations we have
aren't about like we've talked about
hater and I talked about this and a
bunch of interviews which is horror will
always be profitable will always be a
market for horror in the movie and in
the entertainment industry it's just
like if you make a horror movie you will
find someone to give you money for it
because they can always sell it and so
it's one of the few places where you can
have a new voice to be able to utilize
that genre it's like you can you can
tell a type of story that you want to
underneath or you know what I mean like
as long as you can frame it within that
genre
you'll get your movie made you know what
I mean and so that's why I don't see ty
as like a horror person you know like
seeing Sam Raimi like a lot of those
guys they yeah their horror me they were
making horror movies but I don't think
that they're end-all be-all was just to
stick in a genre yeah yeah I think
there's a probably a reason that's why a
lot of great filmmakers start in horror
yeah and I also think we're in kind of
one of those like if we're just talking
about this - you're you're 20 almost 20
years past the 90s and I remember
growing up that what happened was is the
music video and of the like alternative
rock scene as well as even hip-hop to
some degree a lot of directors cut their
teeth in music videos you have Fincher
and Spike Jonze and all those guys and
then they became sort of the the big
voices of the 2000s you know and then
now that no much these music videos
anymore I feel like we're in this part
of the cycle again where it's back to
horror yeah right it's like back to hard
have younger newer voices use horror as
a you know a testing ground hung up
right now on you saying it's it's 20
years after the 90s or anybody put it
that way but it makes you feel really
distant it's crazy man yeah it's 20
years I still think it's like let's put
on kid here whatever there's nothing
wrong with putting on
yeah now that's a horrible song what
disturbs me is something that when I was
a kid and like thought about the 70s is
like cool retro yeah that's why you can
see it on American Horror Story posters
right it looks like the marketing for I
know what you did it looks like the
marketing for wild things actually you
did last summer the pain so are you a
big horror fan outside of work life do
you watch a lot of horror movies I'm but
again this is more like I watch what I
find to be good directors making horror
movies like I'm a big John Carpenter fan
like a really big John Carpenter fan you
know I really like Sam Raimi I think his
best work is actually drag me to hell
yeah drag me house one of my favorites
it's so funny and gross crazy hardest
pg-13 no but they were like he's made
them so much money with spider-man where
he's like I feel like he was like it's
like palate cleanser he's like when I'm
done with spider-man they just were like
go make whatever you want and I think
that's what he did he's cool
he's the greatest too because he makes
movies like that and then he also uses
all the power he has to foster new
talent in the Harz remember to
opportunity is the nicest man ever I've
heard from a lot of people that he is
the nicest kindest man so yeah like Sam
Raimi a lot John Carpenter I know Daniel
Davies who is basically like John's son
who was in his band with him so yeah so
I've told record got put together and
stuff and it's cool
yeah many times very fine I always go on
Halloween I'll text you after the show
for real cuz I Daniel Daniel is a friend
of mine you know what I'm gonna go this
year cuz I think the OCS are playing on
Halloween Oh cuz it's gonna be Halloween
night isn't it
but then I can't go and that makes me
say I don't know I don't know if they're
gonna play or not I haven't talked to
Daniel oh I hope they do but I hope they
do one night before John John son Daniel
Davies is a really talented musician in
his own right and he's the guitar player
in that band but he's started scoring a
lot of stuff and it's cool it sounds
like that some of the stuff he does
sounds more like the really tripped-out
analog Kubrick stuff you know like from
The Shining I'm just I don't know why
I'm plugging Daniel yeah but I might go
see really well cuz he was in a but this
guy for his name but he was like with
friends with ty Segall and in this band
called the coach whips that everybody
was into in LA but they got in the last
couple of years like crazy prog rock so
it's like super D&D kind of metal you
dig it if you're in the horror yeah I
don't know but I'm assuming that because
you like horror movie you must be like a
rush nerd or something you're not know
women like rush maybe not bad yeah no no
way go all the way from John Carpenter
to alt rock and that's about it I'll
tell you this much though you know I've
discovered the male equivalent to rush I
believe is Prince really yeah which is
like my wife's like you wanna listen to
like no friends exactly wow I feel like
Prince is the like you're like yeah
she's cool but I'm never gonna be like
you know what I have to listen to you
right now his raspberry beret world
shattered you do as much design like
world shattered by like I'm like like a
lot of girls don't like rush they hate
rush they're like I can't listen to this
I don't hate rush it just doesn't come
on my players by the way exactly how I
feel about Prince even though I was
listening to Prince this morning weird
like 6:30 in the morning cuz the ship
Pat did you watch the ending in the new
ship
no no he starts off by quoting the
lyrics to party like it's 1999 and
they're really dark they're not they're
not not a party song no that's not a
party song dude check that out did you
like the new the new special I didn't
watch like 30s I was 30 seconds of it Oh
6:30 in the morning I was like I have to
be in the shower I had no time off the
last couple of days very true but yes I
am I'm back to the original question I
am a horror fan what do you guys like
horror music no horror as the car stuff
that you're into my favorite horror
movie of all time is scream that's that
was like the Gateway for me I that's
that's the movie that made me appreciate
har not just on an entertainment value
level but just the craftsmanship and how
it can make that thrill can make me feel
I have a cat named deputy Dewey and
between that and Jurassic Park I'm very
thankful that I was allowed to see those
in theaters when I shouldn't have
because that's what made me not just
someone who likes to go see movies for
fun but who appreciates every single
ounce of blood sweat tears energy money
that goes into it so yours this scream
and what's yours
well I echo all the same things she said
because I think we were born the same
year so probably she doesn't look a day
over 24 ladies and gentlemen I also
would throw in the thing as the thing
yeah John Carpenter yes okay oh that's
good I was you you were kind of dating
you and making me feel old we were like
- scream I feel like you've got more
refined taste than I do I'm very much
like 90 slasher chunk I mean not that
scream is junk but it's like scream was
the obsession I know what you did last
summer dream is cool I forget there was
some film fear theorists critic in like
the 90s and at
I feel like it was kind of like a really
well articulated a thesis that it was
like the reason why all of those movies
were popular in the 80s is because it
was the loss of Victorian values right
and that that scream is basically just
coming right out and saying like yes
that's true right which is the like the
only person who survives that movie is
the person without sin I'm the
babysitter survives because she's still
the version because she overcame her
basically like carnal desires and I mean
by vert being like virtuous she what she
actually didn't want you oh yeah I'm
going back to scream oh yeah but she
almost gets whacked though but I'm more
like got like Halloween sorry I'm like
jumping around yeah but but the screen
right comes right out and says like this
is why sort of underneath all of that
like you know this is this is why we
gravitate towards those movies and I'm
not inclined to disagree with that all
the time no I mean there's a point to it
there's like a lot of belief that the
first wave of slashers were actually
conservative films because they were
punishing anyone who is acting in a you
know circle I don't I don't even get
into the like idea of like moral
conservativism like I don't necessarily
think I don't mean it like that way
necessarily I mean in terms of who was
being punished it was like the people
who are having pretty mature sex doing
drugs those sort of values were what
were being put forth and then sort of
scream would be the one that addressed
it and yeah I think I'm saying like yeah
it was put it was probably the first
postmodern horror movie but there were a
bunch of academic film scholars who
talked about who had sort of like
addressed that even earlier before it so
it's cool for a Wes Craven to come out
and go like yeah no that's exactly what
you know so that's cool scream the thing
there's you know there's a line in did
that right bill hey there's a line in
Chapter two ya know cuz we looked it up
what what does he say [ __ ] what is he oh
god it's like one of the most famous
lines but because you're asking I won't
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
yeah
[ __ ] kidding me yeah we looked it
yeah we remember us filming and we like
we were like what was the line from the
thing where they saw it when we YouTube
Danny was like million to put it in
excellent I throw a lien in there too
daily over salutely yeah are you are you
a lien over aliens yes you - um I don't
know it's so weird man they're so
different
yeah but I just wanna think of the
directors where it's like that Ridley
Scott their first one it's like so slow
most people couldn't be put up with that
today you know like how slow it is I
mean I really enjoy that and then you
know James Cameron's like the second one
and if you kind of break down every
James Cameron thing they're they're
basically just running from something
for like 90 minutes it's like ah that's
what it is and he's really into like
you're being chased you're either being
chased by the sinking ship are you being
chased by the Terminator or you're like
being chased by the aliens underwater by
the way have you ever seen that the
making of the abyss I've never seen that
I highly suggest it's I think it's like
a six-part series in YouTube okay
you should watch the making of the abyss
all of that if anyone out there is like
a movie buff because cuz it chapter two
is a little difficult to film and hate
her and I would talk about it he'd be
like I can't watch this i watch that i
felt so much better i think like it is
the craziest stuff happens on that the
filming of that movie it's like I can't
like I can't believe it I would be like
well I would have killed myself yeah my
follow-up to that regarding a chapter -
and I feel like we should have like a
buzzer or something if you've been asked
this question the crash cart in here I'm
totally fine with that at this point it
chapter - you said was an especially
difficult movie to film no I don't want
to say it was an especially difficult it
was just it was a lot of set pieces that
script was 200 pages yet has nothing to
do with Andy it was like it was a lot of
movie was there anything in particular
that you walked into and you're like I'm
to be fine I got my [ __ ] together for
this and then it's real [ __ ] that so I
don't want to get in there like spoiler
thing but there's a whole big set piece
at the end the whole end sequence there
were a lot of strobe lights there right
like a lot of strobe lights firing in
and out of sequence so and we were
covered in dirt and grime and like I
don't want to complain about being an
actor because it's like it's not that
bad it's not like coal it's not like
coal mining or like going into a
conflict zone or like being at but
there's a certain amount of
psychological torture too cuz you just
do it over and over and over and over
again and so we would leave I wouldn't
know what time of day it was where I'd
like walk in I'd be like what today's
breakfast sir oh my god it's 2:00 in the
morning cuz and then it's like this
strobe light made you insane but I lost
it one day cuz they went off to film a
different scene the rest of them and I
wasn't in it and I had to do second unit
stuff of like this where I was walking
into the thing and they must have done
it 15 times I was like this cuz I got
into a point where I was like oh I'm in
The Truman Show they want to see you
more like you know what they're like the
agent Smith is like this is where we
break Morpheus program and you're just
where you want to break my they want to
see where my thought pattern changes
yeah I think she ate all your entrance
scenes a million times more now yeah and
then they're like then because of what
they would have to do is they would film
it then satellite it'd have to watch
Andy wait to give approval and then come
back and be like no no he wants you to
do it again and do two turns
look around I was like and so then the
joke was like come on man if you mouth
up I'll put you at second unit again and
I'd be like sure is that the typical
process with second unit the idea of
satellite net footage to the director
all the time
no that type of stuff I feel like it it
depends it literally depends you know
but Andy's such a stickler
and this is actually what I appreciate
about it about Andy - it's like if you
like the movie or don't like the movie
there's not one uninteresting frame in
the entire thing like it is young like
oh man every frame there's something
going on in where it was like he's so
because he was a storyboard artist first
right and then he was a director and
what's really cool and a lot of people
don't talk about this and this is some
70 stuff is you know he creature
designed Pennywise that's a really
really big deal like a really big deal
that people don't talk about it
especially if you have any understanding
of the history of cinema right that
stuff is always out sourced right so to
have the director creature design that
stuff is usually outsourced to like big
you know like they'll get together with
an artist and let me like no I wouldn't
wear like this I think he was playing at
cool on set we were there for the first
movie and he was like yeah I did some
sketches like I think he was under
selling the extent to which he designed
it oh yeah for as much as he would get
even like attention to detail with me
which is the like I want you to turn
around twice right he would get when
when Bill skarsgård was on camera it was
like oh I want to move this one like
drip of blood like literally you're like
Fincher level OCD about what the frame
should look like you know so that's why
I like Bill Bill skarsgård has like the
patience of a Zen monk whenever someone
asks me now did you know this about any
machete I'm like hey Lee did you know
that I did not I have interviewed I've
talked to Barbara for the first time the
other day and after you teed her up so
so high I was so nervous to walk into
that room she's like she's actually the
nicest person in the entire world she
feels a little to me like the unsung
hero of the it movies she's yeah it's a
lot of pressure to wrangle seven idiot
children and then seven idiot adults
okay so imagine what imagine being
completely shit-faced on like the
biggest bottle of Jagermeister now
imagine you leave the bar around 2:30
and then the question is is where are we
gonna go next all 14 of your friends
that's exactly what it's like to get
everybody together like Carl would to
get pizza
Amy's crying you know we leave the 1 bar
with all of your where are we going next
in and it's gonna take literally 4 hours
to get half a block away
that is what it's like for Barbara to
wrangle all of these people to get them
onto set and to do it sort of like
without she's she's beautiful
[Laughter]
thread and one day hater sent me a
picture of our first assistant director
Michael Lerner and he's literally like
this and it was not staged she took it
from like across the room I was like oh
Michael is gonna kill himself there's
another unsung hero of a Michael Michael
Lerner just like you throw the script
pages up it's yeah we love he's behind
the scenes stories I mean I think every
movie that gets made is a minor miracle
yeah no no it's not a minor miracle it's
a major miracle movies should not get
made like every time and then again bill
and I were talking about this cuz I've
been doing this for so long it's like
the fact that they even come out yeah
like there's stuff where you're like oh
well there's music for God I was in
because they don't come out you know
you're not kidding
you have like an endless residency to
it's like I have the titles that are at
the top of my head all the time but I
started to scroll through and I'm like
oh he was on that and that
I forgot that I've been I will obviously
never forget sinister in particular
because big will was on my wall for life
and I'm fine with it now years later
scott derrickson was at the premiere the
only what's he really got his kid I'm so
happy for him and what he's doing
yes bring some genre to the MCU please I
didn't I have not seen any of those
movies really I haven't turned on my TV
in five years we don't know each factor
Ian Reed much better for the brain so I
guess safe to assume you are well-read
and Stephen King novels no not all of
them I mean when I was a kid I read the
stand again Ty West gave me ty West gave
me this book it was on writing I think
his best book is on writing did you read
it I did not read that his best book
I've been devouring so I grew up never
reading ever ever ever had so many
people my life who said you have to read
all these Stephen King books cuz it's
right up your alley and it wasn't until
and this is why I love the first it
movie so so much because it opened my
life up to Stephen King ever since that
movie hit theaters I have not stopped
listening to Stephen King audiobooks
that's not the same as reading my
friends don't give there's a cool
performance aspect to it though because
some of the narration it's like goalless
it's not the same as reading it's not
listen to Pet Sematary narrated by
Michael C Hall
I'll read it burn I've got to be able to
run and listen to my books I really know
I really feel like it develops this part
of your brain that helps with
imagination and creative it's joy that
you it's actually more passive than you
think it is and like because your brain
starts conjuring pictures that are
associated with other people's words and
so you're not really even have to work
that hard but then you're a mess you're
using your imagination act passively and
actively and I feel like that will
actually if you do that enough it will
inform a bunch of other creative things
that
you want to do that you have yet to do
that is a very good way to put it I
cannot refute it you don't I mean in
like Ana spit and then I'm like no you
should you should read whatever you like
everybody should read whatever it is
that they like but they should just read
and I don't mean that they should only
read and it's like I don't want to take
that away from people but I got so much
more of joy of reading as an adult than
I did you have my word after the
marathon training is done I will crack
open up a physical body they'll hold it
in my hand
it's a nightmare I can't why 25k no the
fold thing New York City Marathon
November 26.2 how are you doing almost
almost drop dead at 12 miles of my last
half but I managed to plow through and
get to the end you do like did they look
at your gait and your foot and your foot
placement all that stuff a little bit
yeah we have a mutual friend video are
you feeling running are you mid foot
running I've never really thought about
it like whatever whatever my form is is
okay because we have a buddy who's
obviously a professional running coach
and he said I looked I looked okay
double check make sure yeah cuz like I
feel like I feel like mid foot running
doesn't like are you talking about where
your foot pounds the pavement where your
foot actually lands and where you press
off from you should never heel strike no
no no but your heel at that point should
actually never almost touch the ground
okay and learn I'm like learning all
this the stuff that I didn't think I was
born to run how do you start with born
to run
okay do you know about the tour home
Warren and Copper Canyon no it's this
group of Mexican runners that were
running like 50 to 75 miles a day and
they wear the they were that they're
just called like total [ __ ] sandals and
they're basically made of old tire so
that was why they people started
barefoot running nike ruined our feet in
the 70s and like most people he's like
back problems and their postures all
messed up because people can't run walk
correctly what did you say that I should
read Born to Run or interim I think the
desert is just double-check and make
sure it says like something the first
when the first thing that came up was
born Tora Born to Run
a hidden tribe super athletes and the
greatest race the world
that's a docks the title doesn't fit the
world the world has never seen
I don't remember all that I'm not that
big of a reader I did the backwards
though and during my training I listened
to the Long Walk that's like a weird way
to motivate yourself but it worked but I
feel like people fix their back problems
and stuff as they learn how to resin
they started filming you know like those
Africans will run just like 50 to 75
miles an ER then they started studying
where their feet land because they don't
wear shoes
that's like those of the foots a literal
work of art the arch like da Vinci talks
about this to care to be load-bearing
and have that like dorsiflexion and your
ankle it seen it's opened so shoes
ruined us because we started walking and
running incorrectly there was one guy
who did that half the other day
completely barefoot and I looked at him
oh my god I don't know how you do it but
there is a first time I really tried to
do it I realized and run with like
mid-foot strike this is so boring for
your audience so sorry
I'm terribly sorry I like couldn't walk
for three days because when calves
started working again I'm gonna be
thinking about this now with every step
that I take don't forget about this
because you'll just save your body later
okay yeah that's the goal I've heard
horror stories post marathon training no
no just I mean in life if you learn how
to run or walk correctly yeah just like
hitting the right place on your foot I
plan on being able to stand up straight
and doing sports until the day I die so
trust me
most people don't I will take it yeah
well that's the end of the run sorry
guys I know Barbara miss Yeti big cups
of coffee I kind of want to just like
see you and Jack sit down and have a
casual conversation because your cadence
is so on point with his do you guys have
to kind of practice that through before
you hit the set
or is that something you naturally were
just able to do in the movie yeah oh you
know like they slowed down the Steve
Perry tapes to make his voice sound
higher anybody like journey no I'm not
really dating myself no no I just
watched the movie and I thought uh
like okay it was he was speaking so fast
in the first one that I thought like I
don't know if I can actually like I'm
old and tired and then I and then I
don't really practice that much but yeah
I just I just went in and and did it the
best that I could no no no idiot stop in
tears and no one knows going on because
I was wearing a little earpiece I think
a sense of humor I feel like he'd ever
like a really fun snarky way to come at
that yeah I mean oh he likes he's kind
of like uh he's I saw that kid and I was
like that kids a freak he's got such raw
natural what he's able to do on camera
and have you seen like the behind the
scenes stuff and has like ability to
improv it's just it's not a you can't
teach that to it yeah it's so raw and so
like I'm like man that's crazy you know
and then there's similar things I see
there's stuff that I see kind of like in
an overarching that has not little to do
with our like actual like the day-to-day
stuff that we're in do but I'm like oh I
can kind of track how what I think your
life is gonna look like you know I think
things they'll be hard for him at a
certain point because you can't have a
brain that fast
it's it's difficult it's difficult to
relate to people I mean that that's
interesting that you put it that way did
you guys like ever I mean this is no
because he's like 16
I'm like a 40 year old man like you know
I mean like he doesn't want anything to
do yes life is like the most boring
thing that he could possibly imagine the
hard life for any other reason like I
just know what it's like to be able to
like to have the synapses fire that fast
and sometimes you start to go like you
become really self conscious and you're
like wait what's wrong with me
but nothing right like that's the thing
and then you know but it can be when
you're young that [ __ ] can bring up
insecurities you know so or not cuz he's
also like a famous movie star no no no
he's doing good things right now he's
like just to be clear I just feel like I
I know what it's like to be a sensitive
person who thinks very quickly and it's
not always the easiest thing in the
entire world and only with age as I have
Ivan because I just don't care anymore
good thing about aging oh yeah
everything else is really wrong so I'm
stuck what you owe me the rest of my
life then aren't I oh no man I don't I
don't feel that way I don't feel like
everything else kind of sucks there's
parts of it's just great I really
believe I just had a kid and it's like
the best I never thought that I was
gonna want to have a kid and like I'm
like this is so awesome
it's so awesome even though my wife
wants to kill me right now cuz I've been
working for three days straight she's
she she's like this tie back into horror
has having a kid changed the way you
respond to certain things in horror uh
yeah I think so even though the other I
like I didn't watch all of the movie but
like I have a hard time watching
it's just violence on screen now there's
any violence right and especially
especially if the characters are like
superfluous right right so like I had a
whole less to even do with the subject
matter of the con
I just don't like watching violence like
sometimes if you get into the like if
you have the larger characters and
they're subject to sort of like trials
and tribulations but if they're if I'm
if it's a means to an end to propel a
story forward by putting violence in it
I'm like I don't want to see that I just
I'm grossed out by it now that makes
sense because you go like well somebody
gets punched in the face and it's
incidental in the larger part of the
story and you guys know like well I know
why these things happen but I don't like
watching violence or gore for the sake
of it being sort of like hitting a beat
in a story what's an example of positive
affect anything horrific in a movie has
had on you because I don't know
sometimes I find when we see those
extremes on screen it it kind of puts
you know a certain reality I might be
struggling with into a more digestible
package where I might not think about it
the same way otherwise well I think what
even like we were talking about was
scream it's like people got to taste of
like post-modernism where even though
you go the opposite direction where
you're like yeah people were doing drugs
and like all this other stuff I go I
have a flip side of that where people go
we'll wait what does it mean to like be
a teenager and should I like not drink
in a party like should I like maybe not
necessarily just give my virginity away
to like the first idiot [ __ ] that I
date in tenth grade do you know and like
those are valid questions right and as
long as people are questioning that and
if they are having that relationship in
the context of any story then that's
good
right like dogmatism is bad but anybody
that says that as long as people are
having awareness of that stuff for me I
always I don't even know if it's like a
horror movie or do you ever see audition
you know I did yes I do magicians are
rough one we've been talking about that
a lot last couple of days movie oh I
just more in like I like ideas
I like ideas and I like ideas that sort
of live they kind of like a spirit that
leaves the body of the movie that lives
on
for the movies dead does that make sense
like Let The Right One In was had me
thinking about like where people get
stuck in adolescents and and the nature
of how like innocence can be how people
can manipulate then one another by love
and then sex and then the promise of sex
and and sort of like where does
innocence end and where does you know
like adulthood begin and that's that
like watching that movie it's such a
it's such a head [ __ ] because the real
victim of that movie is the little boy
right and she is this thing that's like
older than time who's manipulated his
desire to be loved right and you're like
oh because then you could then you see
that everywhere it's the difference
between a fleeting thrill and a movie
that's like so deep and impactful that
you can't help but to take it with you
and see it everywhere well right so I
brought this up before and people we're
gonna go way off into a tangent if
you're ready for this yes well people go
why did Stephen King why is it have like
so much resonance right why is why does
this it's a movie about a clown and some
kids it's like mmm so what's the so tell
me that's so so what's the exact amount
of time that it takes for Pennywise to
come back how many years 27 years okay
right so in classical astrology Saturn
returns every 27 years
Saturn is also Chronos you know Acronis
is Cronus is the eater of children right
so the king is tapping it you should
there's a Goya painting look at that
right now okay what do we got
type Koya Saturn coria's Saturn eating
was the next thing that came up in
Google oh you know why I've seen this
this was floating around when we were
making child eater Oh
did Stephen King just tap into a larger
universal mythology that has always
existed in the context of like human
understanding and he just happened to
like update it at the right feet just
like software upgraded right do you not
I mean that's really why did people love
this and it's like well because I think
it's always been there 27 years is the
exact time that it takes for Saturn to
go around the elliptical right so it's
like you know we have a 1 year cycle the
earth moves
well it takes 27 for Saturn to do that
right and I don't know whether he like
inadvertently picked up on it or I I
don't think it was a conscious thing I
think people in a clown it's like
because it's this mythology goes back
thousands of years yeah that's
interesting there's a documentary coming
out on alien that's basically the same
thing it's called memory origins of
alien and it's it's all about how alien
is rooted and ancient art and mythology
and we just tell the same stories over
and over again yeah we just tell the
same stories over and over and over and
over again
we should wind down the non-spoiler talk
because we did want to save some time to
talk some it's chapter 2 spoilers with
you but do we want to squeeze in our
last two I think you already gave us so
many recommendations but first up we
always plug some people that are new
that they like I like the sound of that
we always end with the same two
questions given what you just said I'll
go with this one
what is something within the horror
genre that you're reading watching
listening to anything at all that you
would recommend to our viewers and
listeners it's a horror show anything at
all yeah well I would listen to all the
like john carpenter's new records
they're gonna put it there I think
they're putting on something and then
even if you didn't listen to lost themes
because it was a good it was really sick
you know that that was right so it was
like John wasn't gonna make any more
movies and then Daniel has some was like
why don't we make a record together and
so of him and Cody his brother right
they made this record together as if it
was they would be themes for horror
movies that never got made which is cool
very good recommendation their question
- ah yes do you have any pets yes
do you and whether and I sure do names
models all of the details there's Sonny
who's a sort of Nordic Spitz sort of uh
he's like let me just get into the good
that's right so there's Sonny who is a
Nordic Spitz kind of like he kind of
looks like a American Eskimo kind of dog
and then he is 12 he was my dog
then there was pig which is piggy smalls
that's her real name
he's a 12 year olds awawa who's a deer
head she's not very bright but she's
very nice and then I have a cat named
Kevin who can use the toilet sometimes
these shits in the tub and then I have
the baby of the family is a lynx points
I am EA's named Judy who who is like
that's like daddy's little girl or
literally if she leaves the house I
think she died
this one will answer to her own name
which is crazy so like I will call her
and she will vocally respond to her look
and look at that look at that sweet face
blue eyes I know here why'd you guys
offense isn't it and the funny thing is
Dewey talks to me on command
I just can't teach do we had to use the
toilet oh my god you teach Dewey how to
you know who this looks like to Nala cat
yes I know exactly you're talking about
Lynx point Siamese like no no it's like
a whole thing like I've been like if the
whole house burns down I'll be like did
she make it out alive yeah yeah and she
would not I don't know would she care
but if would she be worried about you
making it out of no of course not she'd
really eat me after we had the the
earthquakes recently I tried to invest
in emergency bags and all I did was
purchase an emergency bag for Dewey
that's very
that's really dumb yeah no I know and I
gotta put the other thing back on the
to-do list but he's the priority in life
ice I see it kind of like Milo and Otis
the movie pitch back on the whistling my
Louise traumatized me more than any
other horror movie as a child I just
cannot watch that one anymore alright so
this is where we are gonna draw the line
if you are leaving us because you have
not seen it chapter two yet thank you
for listening you have survived a
portion of this witching hour but come
back after you've seen the movie cuz
we're gonna have spoiler talk with James
so goodbye
here is the spoiler you probably left
when we're talking about feet anyway
[Music]